here is Democrat activist Jake Tapper on
CNN and he brought on Maryland governor
Larry Hogan now Larry Hogan is if you
listen to the mainstream media if you
listen to the corporate press I know you
guys don't but if you listen to them
this is one of the guys that they really
think will be a great Republican and
anytime that the mainstream media tells
you that a republican is great and he's
going to be the guy and all that stuff
that means he's nothing right Liz Cheney
think of this guy as sort of a Liz
Cheney there are no Republicans that
like him so he gets on CNN all the time
so here is former Maryland governor
Larry Hogan on Democrat activist Jake
Tapper show on fake news CNN going after
Ron DeSantis Governor Ron DeSantis is
often cited by conservative Republicans
as somebody they might want to see run
for president you've called him an
important voice one of the important
voices for the party do you think he
would be good at what you're talking
about in terms of reaching out to people
in the middle well he hasn't done it so
far I mean he's done a really good job
of getting on Fox News and he's
capturing lot of attention but he
certainly hasn't done it the way Charlie
Baker and Phil Scott and I have I mean I
you know we we're consistently the most
highest job approval in the country and
I think the santis is down around 30th
Place among Governors is that because
he's too focused on the base too focused
on red meat issues well I just think
that he is focused on the base and he's
he's doing pretty well with the base but
uh he's gonna have to figure out a way
if he if he wants to have a political
future Beyond Florida to appeal
I mean it's so extraordinary once you
see as I always say like once you see it
you can never unsee it so you need to
understand Larry Hogan's running for
president he has literally no support
he'll be in and out over overnight but
the media will prop him up because he'll
go after the guy that's the real threat
I bet he sits there with a straight face
and oh and I'm the guy me and Charlie
Charlie Baker I was going to say Charlie
Parker the great jazz musician were the
guys that are the crossover people okay
it's so patently ridiculous and just on
its face Rhonda said is just one in
perhaps the biggest Landslide one of the
biggest landsides in American political
history he took a state that was very
very purple because it was always
flipping between red and blue and now
they have super majorities the
Republicans he won by 20 points there he
turned uh districts like Miami-Dade red
when they are The Bluest blue
strongholds ever he has all of the
independence he has all of the new
refugees you don't even have to hear me
say that just look at the numbers these
people didn't appear out of nowhere on
top of the fact that I can tell you as
as someone that's been here for a year I
go all over this state I do tons of
events everywhere I have talked to
hundreds if not thousands of people who
are telling me that they are former
Democrats who are now here because of
Freedom thanks to what Geron DeSantis is
doing I myself
I'm a first-time registered Republican
because of Ron DeSantis and what the
good people of Florida have been doing
so you need to just understand the
reason I'm showing you that is that's
what they do when you get someone who
will stand up for America who will stand
up for the Constitution who will stand
up for your right to live as you see fit
the machine
CNN Jake Tapper Larry Hogan all of the
hacks will come out of nowhere and try
to take them out this guy has no support
Charlie Baker has no support but the
machine just like they did with Liz
Cheney who then lost by 40 points to
Harriet Hageman right but they loved her
in her January 6th commission and all of
that stuff so that's why they're trying
to take this guy out
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]